casi en su lema ni era el general más
importante que tenía no solamente los
guardianes revolucionarios sino toda la
institución militar de irán y casi en
oriente medio' era un experto en guerra
de guerrillas era un experto en
contrainsurgencia y tuvo un papel muy
importante en muchísimos desde la guerra
con irak en la década de los 80 pero
especialmente también durante el ascenso
de isis especialmente en irak él jugó un
papel muy importante en reorganizar esas
fuerzas iraquíes que habían quedado
básicamente destruidas en el momento que
inició entra en el país pero también
jugaba un papel simbólico en irán- era
como la gran figura después del líder
supremo representaba ese movimiento que
para la revolución islámica es tan
importante que es la resistencia contra
lo que ellos llaman el estado sionista e
israel y adicionalmente tenía un gran
relación con todos estos líderes pro
iraníes en la región hasán nasralá en el
líbano con nosotros líderes en ir a por
eso su pérdida puede muy dolorosa para
iraní y ha tenido también un gran
impacto en toda la región porque
representaba ese símbolo hay bastantes
opiniones encontradas sobre si fue
efectivo para eeuu haberlo asesinado
muchos piensan que vino en su contra
debido a que es mucho más difícil para
iran organizar y tener el control y la
coordinación con esos grupos que son
aliados en la región